[Música]
Durante los primeros días del 2022 solo
se hablaba de una cosa vienen los rusos
la acumulación de tropas en la frontera
con Ucrania parecía dejar Claro que la
invasión era cuestión de tiempo sin
embargo en aquel momento las
expectativas que tenía Prácticamente
todo el mundo eran las de un paseo
triunfal lo recordáis 15 de febrero de
2022 las armas estadounidenses enviadas
a Ucrania mitigarían pero no detendrían
una invasión rusa el ejército ruso
podría abrumar rápidamente a las fuerzas
armadas ucranianas incluso a las que
están respaldadas por Estados Unidos y
sus aliados europeos 5 de enero de 2022
el ejército de Ucrania tiene fondos
insuficientes está superado en armas y
no está listo para detener una invasión
rusa Estos son tan solo dos ejemplos de
lo que parecía un consenso general salvo
sorpresa mayúscula a las fuerzas armadas
de Ucrania no tenían nada que hacer ante
la gigantesca y poderosa maquinaria
bélica de Rusia En aquel momento se
hablaba de cosas como la evacuación de
zelensky o la puesta en marcha de una
guerra de guerrillas Sin embargo los
ucranianos resistieron y lo hicieron
Contra viento y marea
[Música]
durante meses y meses los ucranianos han
visto como sus ciudades sus pueblos y
sus campos están siendo arrasados Las
bajas por su parte se cuentan por
decenas y decenas de miles los rusos han
destruido centrales eléctricas miles de
colegios cientos de hospitales y todo
tipo de infraestructuras para que os
hagáis una idea en abril del 2023 la
estimación de los daños directos
provocados por la guerra superaba ya los
150.000 millones de dólares los
ucranianos han tenido que hacer frente a
las Bombas al frío y a la oscuridad y
sin embargo han resistido Y no sólo eso
ahora incluso vuelven a tener la
iniciativa digamos que los ucranianos no
estaban dispuestos a perder esta guerra
bajo ninguna circunstancia y ahora ahora
quieren ganarla la pregunta la gran
pregunta que todavía no hemos respondido
es por qué los ucranianos pesa todo
quieren seguir luchando pues queridos
amigos amigas aquí en visualpolitik
ahora mismo lo vamos a ver
[Aplausos]
[Música]
Pero antes dejadme haceros solo un
apunte te gusta lo que hacemos quieres
ayudarnos a crecer y al mismo tiempo a
recibir un montón de contenido extra
pues tan solo tenéis que sumaros a
nuestra comunidad de patrón con una
pequeñísima ayuda podéis hacer que este
proyecto siga creciendo y mejorando y
además recibiréis nuestro boletín
especial las claves de la semana
merchando y sin único y mucho más
contenido os dejamos toda la info en la
descripción Muchísimas gracias De
corazón a todos los que ya nos dais
vuestro apoyo y ahora sí arranquemos
[Aplausos]
[Música]
creo que si hay algo lo que todos
podemos estar de acuerdo y sin el gran
mérito que ha tenido la resistencia
numantina de Ucrania vale que ahora
sabemos que el armamento y el ejército
ruso tenían más agujeros que un queso
gruyer vale que ahora sabemos que la
enorme corrupción lo ha dejado seco y
vale que todos hemos visto los enormes
lujos de arma que han llegado Ucrania
desde sus aliados occidentales pero
claro pese a todo haber resistido contra
un ejército superior en número en armas
en fuerza aérea en artillería y
prácticamente en cualquier campo es algo
que tiene mucho pero que muchísimo
mérito pongámonos en su lugar no es nada
fácil ver como el oso ruso se te
abalanza encima y mantener el cuchillo
entre los dientes y sin embargo eso es
exactamente lo que han hecho los
ucranianos por supuesto el precio a
pagar ha sido altísimo y lo será aún más
en Ucrania la destrucción la
aniquilación y Las bajas son ya el pan
de cada día recordáis las imágenes que
dejó la voladura de la presa de Nova
kahofra pues así con todo y sin embargo
a pesar de ello las encuestas dicen que
la inmensa mayor parte de los ucranianos
quieren luchar hasta el final que
quieren echar a los rusos de su país
oeste lo que cueste no me creéis pensáis
que exagero pues fijaos más del 80% de
los ucranianos se oponen a las
concesiones territoriales a una riesgo
de una guerra prolongada Pero cómo es
posible que con todo en contra no
decidieran bajar los brazos Cuando
comenzó la invasión Por qué no lo hacen
ahora porque villantres quieren los
ucranianos a seguir peleando por qué
tanto si tantos jóvenes están dispuestos
a llegar hasta el final
queridos amigos amigas la resistencia
ucraniana tiene varios ingredientes que
se han ido cocinando A fuego lento y
sabéis que para conocer el primero de
ellos tenemos que remontarnos Ni más ni
menos que hasta comienzos del siglo XX
concretamente hasta octubre de 1917
cuando la revolución estalló en el
Imperio Ruso y todo saltó por los aires
también en Ucrania que primero se
proclamó como una República
independiente de Rusia y luego sufrió
una guerra civil entre dos bandos la
República popular ucraniana asistida por
Alemania y el Imperio austrohúngaro por
un lado y la República socialista
soviética de Ucrania apoyada por los
bolcheviques por otro al final fueron
estos segundos Quienes se llevaron al
gato al agua y en 1922 Ucrania se unió a
Rusia Bielorrusia y tras los caucasia
para formar la URSS la unión de
repúblicas socialistas soviética Moscú
volvía a estar al mando lo que el tiempo
demostró que fue un absoluto desastre
[Música]
para la década de los años 30 los
beneficios de haberse integrado en la
unión soviética prácticamente habían
desaparecido la política agraria de
stalin basada en la confiscación y la
colectivización de las tierras afectó
como a ningún otro a un territorio que
era conocido como el granero de la URSS
los campesinos que trataron de mantener
su tierra fueron reprimidos deportados a
campos de concentración incluso
ejecutados
el resultado murieron de hambre entre
3,5 y 8 millones de ucranianos en el
mejor de los casos hablamos de que más
del 10% de la población de Ucrania se
murió de hambre por culpa de las
decisiones tomadas en Moscú fue lo que
posteriormente se ha conocido como
lodomor pero amigos eso no fue más que
el comienzo Durante los años del
estalinismo el supremo promovió
activamente la dosificación de Ucrania
lo que suponía restringir e incluso
suprimir el uso del ucraniano Y de
cualquier otro aspecto de la cultura
local por supuesto todo esto significó
mucha más represión tras stalin los
ucranianos tuvieron un breve tiempo de
respiro Durante la etapa de Nikita
kussef al frente del imperio rojo pero
después en Moscú volvieron a las mismas
[Música]
y luego tras años de pobreza y mano dura
para colmo en 1986 se produjo el
desastre de Chernobyl que fue otra vez
terriblemente mal gestionado por la
cúpula soviética de Moscú así que ya lo
veis durante décadas Moscú y por tanto
Rusia y los rusos por extensión no
hicieron que digamos muchos puntos para
ganarse el corazón de los ucranianos y
quizás por eso tras la preestroika y el
colapso de la unión soviética en octubre
de 1991 los ucranianos lo tuvieron muy
pero que muy claro querían volver a ser
un país independiente y como decimos por
aquí dicho y hecho los ucranianos
votaron en un referéndum y la
independencia ganó por una aplastante
mayoría y ojo porque tal y como podéis
ver de Independencia ganó en todas las
regiones del país ganó por inmensa
mayoría en el donbas y también ganó en
crimea y en sebastopol claro que hubo un
momento porque no la independencia no
logró que los tentáculos y la influencia
de Moscú se terminara todo lo contrario
[Música]
perdiendo el tren a Bruselas
en prácticamente todos los países
posoviéticos la transición para dejar
atrás el comunismo fue terriblemente
dura Todo estaba por hacer y por
supuesto no querían las cosas no fueron
diferentes el sector público era un
desastre el gigantesco aparato Estatal y
las asfixiante dependencia de Moscú
estaba por todas partes y los países
tenían que reconstruirse de arriba a
abajo en medio de una brutal crisis
económica para que os hagáis una idea
entre 1991 y 1998 la economía de Ucrania
se llegó a desplomar más de un 60 por
ciento Sí sí lo habéis escuchado bien un
60% de locos y de hecho no empezó a dar
síntomas de mejora hasta la llegada del
nuevo siglo pero luego unos pocos años
después llegó la gran crisis financiera
y todo se fue otra vez al garete un
desastre el país parecía condenado a no
poder escapar del pozo sin embargo tras
la gran crisis del 2008 algo cambió de
pronto surgió la posibilidad de firmar
un acuerdo de asociación con la Unión
Europea y sabéis lo que esto significaba
amigos el acceso al mercado común podría
cambiarlo todo de repente los productos
uc nianos podrían fluir hacia el oeste
como si no hubiera mañana y las
inversiones europeas podrían ayudar a
modernizar todo el país sin embargo con
tened Euforia porque había un problema y
no precisamente uno pequeño adivináis
cuál 321 Exacto
Moscú
[Música]
las negociaciones con la Unión Europea
empezaron viento en popa y a toda vela
sin embargo cuando parecían estar a
punto de llegar a buen puerto de repente
descarrilaron por completo el presidente
Victoria nukovic que había prometido
sacar adelante este acuerdo congeló el
proceso por supuesto detrás de este
movimiento estaba Rusia 21 de noviembre
de 2013 Ucrania abandona su plan de ir
hacia occidente y gira hacia oriente El
Primer Ministro llanucovich dio la
dramática orden de suspender el proceso
en interés de la seguridad nacional y
reanudar el diálogo activo con Moscú la
idea de que las repúblicas exoviéticas
fueran por ahí coqueteando con occidente
era lo que Putin no Estaba dispuesta a
consentir le molestaba más que Drácula
un ajo en el desayuno Así que yanukovic
y todos los ucranianos se tendrían que
rendir a su poder el problema El
problema querida comunidad es que en
2013 al igual que en 2022 el presidente
ruso no calibró bien la voluntad de los
cranianos por No dejarse mangonear Y
entonces entonces se desató el desastre
atentos
[Aplausos]
la obstinada esperanza
[Música]
el día 22 de noviembre de 2013 nada más
anunciarse la congelación del acuerdo
con la Unión Europea la Plaza de la
independencia de kiev habitualmente
conocida como maidan empezó a ponerse Al
rojo vivo partidos políticos plataformas
sociales activistas de repente esta
Plaza se convirtió en el epicentro de
una gigantesca protesta una gigantesca
protesta de miles y miles de personas
contra el gobierno toda la oposición a
sus lazos como Moscú estaban
representados en este lugar
era exactamente el mismo lugar donde en
el año 2004 se había producido la
revolución naranja contra el robo
electoral para ser presidente al mismo
yanukovic en detrimento de su oponente
proeuropeo Víctor yuchenko quien por
cierto fue envenenado durante la campaña
electoral de ese mismo año que quien lo
envenenó no se ha podido determinar pero
ya os imaginaréis A dónde se dirigen
todas las sospechas en este caso como en
tantos otros todos los caminos apuntan a
Moscú
pero no nos desviemos
El caso es que la situación es calor
rápidamente y enero del 2014 el gobierno
intentó desalojar la plaza mediante una
dura represión que dejó decenas de
muertos y heridos en ese momento los
manifestantes organizaron creando
unidades de defensa Ucrania estaba al
borde del Abismo pero por fortuna todo
terminó con la dimisión y la huida del
país del presidente llanukovic lo que
por otra parte significaba una dura
derrota para Moscú pero un momento todo
terminó de verdad pues Por supuesto que
no Vladimir Putin no iba a quedarse de
brazos cruzados Así que Seguro seguro
que todos recordáis noticias como estas
1 de marzo del 2014 la invasión rusa de
crimea Aviva el temor a un conflicto en
Ucrania 7 de marzo de 2014 21
periodistas han confirmado que las
tropas enmascaradas en crimea son rusas
efectivamente en la mesa y decidió
contraatacar lo hizo invadiendo primero
y anexionándose después la provincia
ucraniana de crimea al mismo tiempo
alimentó una guerra civil en el don más
la región más rica y desarrollada de
todo Ucrania y amigos en ese momento
este país no pudo hacer prácticamente
nada Solo unos 50.000 soldados podrían
haberse desplegado Cuando comenzó la
guerra en crimea en febrero de 2014 pero
de esos solo alrededor de 6000 estaban
listos para el combate la operación rusa
terminó efectivamente con dos salvajes
derrotas de las fuerzas ucranianas
análisis de la jamestown foundation
Julio de 2021 el resultado la pérdida de
crimea y la proclamación de dos nuevas
repúblicas hoy anexionadas también por
Rusia la República Popular de donex y la
República Popular de lugangs dos estados
títeres de Moscú y sabéis que esta
operación también fue un auténtico
desastre
[Música]
en las nuevas repúblicas las
instituciones formas saltadas se impuso
un modelo internacionalista
ultraconservador y ultramilitarizado
muchas por no decir la mayoría de las
grandes empresas y de los activos
productivos Como por ejemplo las minas o
las fábricas de acero fueron expropiadas
opuestas a disposición de oligarcas el
resultado de toda esta operación que la
actividad económica se hundió y los
empleos desaparecieron se calcula que
cerca de la mitad ojo la mitad de toda
la población hizo las maletas y se
marchó a Rusia al resto de Europa y
sobre todo al resto de Ucrania sobre
todo a regiones próximas como jarquín y
evidentemente tal y como os podéis
imaginar hoy a todas estas personas
Moscú Pues tampoco es que les trasladé
emociones precisamente positivas fijaos
en lo que decía un escritor de la región
a finales del 2021 han logrado
reconstruir un sistema soviético en los
territorios ocupados y no el sistema
soviético de las décadas de los 60 y 70
sino el sistema soviético de las décadas
de 1930 y 1940 con mazmorras con cámaras
de tortura un sistema donde las vidas se
arruinan si te atreves a escribir o
decir algo negativo sobre esta
repúblicas y sus autoridades Stanislao
así novelista y periodista de dones Y
eso eso no es todo la intervención rusa
hizo que Ucrania se viera obligada a
reconstruir sus fuerzas armadas es que
por culpa del kremelín desde comienzos
del año 2014 el que era el país más
pobre de toda Europa tuvo que más que
duplicar su gasto militar
desde luego el tiempo les dio la razón
hacía mucha falta la buena noticia para
Ucrania fue que la ayuda internacional
también comenzó a llegar Justo a partir
de ese momento fijaos 24 de febrero de
2015 entrenamiento militar del Reino
Unido en Ucrania movimientos simbólico
que pone en riesgo la ira rusa 23 de
noviembre de 2015 las tropas
estadounidenses comienzan a entrenar a
las fuerzas regulares ucranianas y así
poco a poco fue como Ucrania y sobre
todo los ucranianos se fueron preparando
para la guerra Hasta que el 24 de
febrero del 2022 Putin finalmente desató
su tormenta de fuego Claro que desde
entonces ha pasado mucho tiempo y la
guerra no solo continúa sino que ahora
son los propios ucranianos quienes están
llevando la iniciativa pero realmente
Qué explica su enorme tenacidad
queridos amigos amigas hagamos si os
parece un pequeño ejercicio imaginémonos
por un momento que volvemos al día 25 de
febrero de 2022 somos ucranianos y somos
jóvenes la invasión rusa acaba de
comenzar los misiles caen sobre Ucrania
al tiempo que las hordas de Putin
intentan alcanzar las principales
ciudades del país incluyendo Claro está
la capital hemos nacido en una Ucrania
independiente donde sin embargo los
tentáculos de Moscú están por todas
partes tus abuelos te han hablado de los
lodo de amor y de los familiares que
perdieron por culpa de Moscú también te
han contado como la unión soviética
intentó rusificar Ucrania tus padres te
han hablado de lo difícil que fue su
vida de la represión Y seguramente
también de la policía política la temida
kgb has leído y quizás visto la serie de
hbo sobre el desastre de Chernobyl Has
vivido el intento de Moscú de que tu
país cortara sus lazos con occidente y
la posterior revolución de la humanidad
has conocido el horror de la guerra del
2014 Y puede que conozcas a gente que
murió que fue víctima o que fue
movilizada durante ese conflicto pero
pese a todo durante los últimos años has
soñado con que Ucrania se modernice y se
abraza a los países más ricos y
prósperos de Europa pero ahora en cambio
vuelves a presenciar como el gobierno
ruso otra vez sigue destrozando y
aniquilando tu país con bombas misiles
tanques y soldados Así que la pregunta
que seguramente tú te harías al igual
que se la han hecho y se la siguen
haciendo muchos ucranianos es como
demonios no luchar
[Música]
amigos de esta forma la mayoría de los
ucranianos han llegado una conclusión
muy clara o derrotan a Rusia de una vez
por todas o nunca podrán tener un país
normal próspero y en paz Rusia se ha
convertido en su peor pesadilla sin
embargo si lo consiguen si ahora
consiguen derrotar a Rusia en unos pocos
años Ucrania podría llegar a
incorporarse a la Unión Europea
incorporarse a la otan e intentar
asimular el impresionante desarrollo de
países como Polonia o la república
bálticas Y eso eso es exactamente lo que
explica la noticia que veíamos antes más
del 80% de los ucranianos se oponen a
las concesiones territoriales a una
riesgo de una guerra prolongada como
podéis ver en los resultados de esta
encuesta dirigida por el Instituto
internacional de sociología de gif los
ucranianos mayoritariamente están
dispuestos a seguir luchando para
recuperar su territorio ya lo veis es
Por así decirlo una apuesta de todo o
nada La pregunta es lo conseguirán
lograrán derrotar a Rusia si fuese
ucraniano Cómo hubiera reaccionado ante
la invasión rusa déjanos como siempre
tus impresiones en los comentarios y
hablamos debate y ahora si este vídeo te
resultó interesante No olvides darle a
like y si te gusta lo que hacemos
quieres echarnos una mano y al mismo
tiempo recibir más contenido Date un
paseo por nuestro patreon os dejamos en
la descripción toda la información y
ahora sí muchas gracias por estar ahí un
saludo y hasta la próxima
[Música]